do you feel like this also affects the
way that you see other people meaning
instead of seeing them do something to
you you actually see their pain
and their
patterning perhaps as opposed to why'd
you do that to me like you can actually
see their
light instead of the projection
exactly and and you can see that's where
they are
that and and and you don't have this if
somebody asked for your help you would
just do anything and give it you're not
overcome with this well i need to fix
everybody you know because everybody is
just in the perfect place where they are
they're they're exactly where they're
meant to be
somebody wrote in to me and said how do
i get back on track and i said well
you're never off track
ever
explain that what does that mean for
them when you're like don't worry about
it everything is perfect you're right on
track what is that what should that be
telling them
well because immediately you look for
first of all immediately you let go of
resistance so the mind is saying oh
you're off track you're off track and
then you believe it and then you then
you create it and then you feel like
you're off track and i'm saying but
you're actually on track you're
perfectly on track now if i could have
had a conversation with the person i
would have said to them
are you the one that's off track or are
you the one who is aware
that you're off track are you the one
that's aware or are you the one that's
off track
and we're always the one that's aware
which is the observer right your
observer and so
and so that kind of frees you up right
away because it stops the mind from kind
of getting you
and having you identify with this
concept that the mind just made up it
just made up this concept you're off
track
we swallowed it hook line and sinker
we're perpetuating it i'm off track i
believe it i'm off track i'm off track
no you're not you're perfectly on track
and and then to look at it in in an even
bigger perspective is that we are always
exactly where we're meant to be
and robert adams used to say everything
is unfolding exactly as it should
and
and
everyone is going to be fine in the end
none of us can be hurt or harmed in the
anonymous we're all eternal
and it's up to everybody to discover
that about themselves and i can only
encourage people and say it's the
greatest journey you will ever take
um is to find out who you are and to
free yourself it's really really
wonderful but there's you know there's
death of the body sure but there's not
death of the consciousness of who we are
and so we're just here having fun
i'm curious if you feel like
you come into that we come into life as
people with a purpose and a mission
i'm asking that because the the secret
is all about manifesting your life and
asking the universe and sort of
allowing the flow of things so
do you feel like you came in with a
purpose in some of your stories you talk
about this knowing that you have and you
know there's like it's almost like it's
like this tiny bit of information that
unlocks this huge vast library of
of of content and knowing and so i
wonder where you stand on that do you
feel like you came in with a mission um
i do
and definitely
the secret was a part of that for sure i
mean i looked back
on my life and i just saw how
i had just been shaped all the way along
for that moment
i just felt that my entire life was
was heading toward that moment even to
the point of
to give you an example
i worked in
television and i worked in news and um
and so i was very aware of news
manipulating stories the way that they
wanted to manipulate them and so when
the secret became massive i had
every
show and organization
wanting to interview me newspapers and
everything and
i knew because of my experience with
news that if i succumbed to all of that
and did all of that there would just be
this thing of building you up and then
tearing you down
and i knew not to do it now i would
never have known that had i not had the
experience in news and so i was very
careful about what i did i did oprah
because i knew
that oprah lived her life you know this
that this way and so i was very
particular about what i did the other
thing was
was that i wanted to make sure that the
message was
the star and not
um not me
and
i'm i'm happy to be there to say this is
what i discovered and i had to share it
with the world and i really did i i just
i couldn't have lived
without sharing this it just it was a
force that was coming through me so i
definitely know that the journey that i
ended up on was the journey that i was
meant to be on however i want to say
that it's the same for everybody it's
just that it it's so more easily marked
maybe with the secret you know because
it was a big event but with everybody's
lives you know there may be a mother and
she has three children and she does all
of these things of bringing up the
children and the children grow up to be
beautiful human beings
that is
exactly what she was meant to do she is
meant to be the beautiful mother to have
that experience to to shape those beings
her children and so i i i just know that
that's why we're on track in any given
moment even if we're hurting